activities into the world of Valhalla  such as River raids tombs of the Fallen  Mastery challenges and more recently the  roguelite Forgotten Saga today I'm  excited to announce that in a few months  time we will also be launching the last  chapter so let's take an exclusive first  look  [Music]  an arbor of memories stretching far into  the past  I have done all I can for my people  it is time to say goodbye one set forth  for Distant Shores and new adventures  fascinating  grappled with Odin's memories in a way  unfamiliar to me  where will this new conflict take you I  wonder  foreign  which nicely ties up some of the  storylines established throughout the  game we'll see evil reunite with some  key characters including some  influential historical ones we can't  wait for you to experience it back to  you Danny and Alice